upon arrival health care is crucial
children will need psychosocial care
many will have missed out on proper
nutrition
standard pediatric vaccinations will be
prioritized
and commission is supporting the supply
of vaccines through here
inside ukraine genuine humanitarian
corridors must be established to to
evacuate the most vulnerable we are
providing substantial humanitarian aid
work
with our international partners and in
coordination with ukrainian authorities
to ensure humanitarian aid reaches its
destination and the children can receive
protection
this war will mark the children of
ukraine for life
we will not leave a stone unturned to
ensure that they will be well cared for
that they can recover and be a child
again
this is not only a job
it is our collective responsibility and
a human imperative thank you very much
thank you very much vice president
schwitzer and i now give the floor to
commissioner ilva johansson
thank you madame president
good morning
putin's army
has so far killed a reported
158 children in ukraine
and wounded many more
last month russian soldiers shot
matwie
eight years old
and his little brother four-year-old
klim
and their mother margarita
as they tried to escape the hell of
butcher
these war crimes
must not go unpunished
eurojust and europol will have a key
role to play here
about 2 million children escaped ukraine
with their lives
many children now face a new danger
a danger i warned of here in plenary
last time we met here in strasbourg
nearly one month ago
the danger of trafficking
your resolution shows that you share my
concerns
lithuanian authorities are investigating
possible trafficking of 43 children for
adoption
there are no confirmed cases yet
but we know from bitter experience
that the danger is real
children are at the top of our agenda
key among the 10 priorities i presented
at the extraordinary council last week
priorities for welcoming people fleeing
the war
our aim
to protect children
from war zone to safe home
last month member states pledged to
welcome more than 15 500 ukrainian
refugees from moldova
512 have now arrived in the eu many of
them children
my services are working on standard
operating procedures for transferring
unaccompanied minors between member
states
making clear
when registering relocating referring
children we must never forgot they are
children
and keep their best interest in mind
the eu agency for asylum will play a
central role we are working with the
agency on common guidance and standards
and i cannot praise unicef enough for
their great job that for the great job
they are doing protecting children in
the eu and in ukraine
and since day one i've been working to
prevent trafficking starting at the eu
border where 282 front tech staff are
helping to identify people at risk or
from trafficking
europol is gathering intelligence
coordinating police cooperation
monitoring online activities by
potential traffickers and by people
trying to exploit the services of
victims
europol has set up a specific task force
against trafficking in human beings to
work with law enforcement
in ukraine and in eu countries along the
border
many member states are warning against
the dangers of trafficking with websites
and hotlines handling out leaflets at
train stations increasing police
presence
our agency for law enforcement training
sepal is teaching border guards police
and others to identify potential victims
and traffickers
we issued calls to use our eu funds to
prevent and fight trafficking and
support victims
last july i appointed diane smith as eu
anti-trafficking coordinator
right away in the first week of war she
activated the network of national
repertoires against trafficking of human
beings and they have already met twice
she visited romania poland together with
your intergroup on children's rights and
she is doing a very important job in
these days
our priority now is registration
registration registration
we need to know where these children are
all 2 million not one child can go
missing
the member states need to step up on
registration
eu lisa is starting technical work to
put in place a platform so the member
states can exchange information a
platform for registration
we also need to register providers of
housing and transport so refugees know
who is safe who they can trust
as my colleague dubrovka vice president
suis i just said we have set up the
solidarity platform to coordinate
efforts it has met twice a week since
the war started
soon the solidarity platform will meet
in a session dedicated to protecting
children to discuss issues member states
can only address together
how to trace children
boosting registration in member states
of arrival and destination
reception capacities for children
also children with disabilities
cooperation with ukrainian authorities
and to endorse an action plan against
trafficking of human beings we must also
work on family reunification
honorable members our great challenge
still lies ahead of us
the longer this war goes on the greater
the risk to children
and just imagine that you are ukrainian
mother
or father
looking at your three children
having to take a very very difficult
decision
should we keep the children here
where we know they are in danger
or
should we send them with our friends
our friend and her two children who will
leave soon
on a potential also dangerous journey to
the european union
and knowing the risk that this might be
the last time we see our children
so many ukrainian parents
have been forced to take this very very
difficult decision
these ukrainian parents want us to keep
their children safe
they count on us
so let's show them that they can count
on us thank you
thank you very
very much commissioner johansson and now
we go to the representatives of the
different political groups starting with
the epp group evacopace
ladies and gentlemen
thank you
very much uh the commission
uh for um
taking
up the issue
uh
regrettably the council is not present
one year ago we
discussed
the first strategy
for the rights of children and now we
lack words
to uh
talk about
the
um
harrowing images from ukraine
butcher
is the latest uh
place where uh
new horrors took place
one cannot find words to describe that
every second child in ukraine
has left
um
their homes they don't sleep in their
beds they don't go to school
very often uh they have been separated
from their families and
friends today
we'll be
undermining we will be
emphasizing
that we need to
provide
ensure
a children's rights to education and
other rights
and
we should ensure
to these children all that that the
russian aggression deprived them of
we must protect those children that uh
are not being protected
um children
unaccompanied
minors
orphans
but we must not be naive
there will be also people that will want
to use the victims of this war and
therefore
we need a
an effective system of registration
of
children
because how can can we
support
and protect children uh that we
don't
know of
and we must not commit
errors we must do more
because
the ukrainians are now entrust us with
their children
and
uh young people this is our great
responsibility
also to make sure that these children
can return
to their
families
and that they learn about the values of
europe values that
should always be protected
next for the s d group iracia garcia
perez
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen thank you president
we're hearing every day worse and worse
news from ukraine and we're not talking
about what's happening at the front
either
what is really terrible is that the
horrific
atrocity
this
macabre scene on the streets
it seems day by day there's a
fight between humanity and
evil
we can still see before our very eyes
the bombing of
a hospital in mario poll where pregnant
women and babies were killed these are
crimes that we shall not give up on
until we have found those who are guilty
but we have to try and mitigate the
worst things the crazy events uh
stemming from
mr putin's actions children shouldn't
have to experience war and we have to
try and bring this to a close as soon as
possible but seven and a half million
children who lived in ukraine have now
had to leave their homes
and
their
lives have changed from one day to the
next some have to go into hiding some
have to leave their cities some have to
go to other countries maybe they have to
even leave their families their parents
their grandparents
the eu
can and must help these people
regardless of the situation and find
themselves
measures
that
people's childhood is being protected
together with the
government of ukraine we need drinking
water accommodation
we need hygiene products many many more
aspects of as well but let's not forget
that these are children and need places
to play to continue going to school
psychosocial support and also moving on
to the humanitarian corridors we cannot
allow that there are
those people who are fleeing are being
killed in cold blood the eu has to work
with international organizations to make
sure that people can be
evacuated in a safe way and that these
people are protected these people are
particularly vulnerable of course and
susceptible to mafia groups which are
active there and they're also volunteers
of course who are going to stations to
pick people up to help but there are
some people who just pretend that
they're there to help and then later
they exploit children and women so the
authorities have to be involved as well
so these huge
streams of
people need to be taken care of but we
need to
try and harness the
good will that exists but at the same
time have to make sure that no woman and
no child ends up in the hands of those
who would do them ill
given
what we're trying to do in the eu and
this platform for solidarity there's
some good things being done the
exchanges between the eu and the
agencies the eu and others are being
facilitated and of course we have to
work
on looking at the un convention for
children which has been
ratified by the russian federation at
the time so children have to be
protected
and we have to make sure that we
consider the well-being of all children
and
not to forget the aspects of human
rights that
pertain to this
you might think it seems unattainable
but we have to try and build a world
with peace
solidarity
and we need to show that this is
possible we hope that the politicians in
russia will understand that soon too on
behalf of the renew group i invite hilda
outmaster take the floor
thank you valentifu
thank you very much president
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
since the 24th of february
there's just one thing that we're
looking at and that is the horror of the
war in ukraine
we
see it as we get up in the morning and
as we go to bed at night
and we've seen the terrible pictures
from
the maternity hospital in maripool and
then
now we're seeing
this terrible images of the bloodbath in
barucha
millions of people are fleeing
and i want to take my responsibility
also as the chair of the intergroup for
children and i'd like to
thank you president that because
our commissioner because you had the
courage to go to the spot
to show that europe cares thank you very
much for being there on behalf of all of
us president
and i'm also very happy that
this session is mainly about ukraine
we're looking
yesterday we were looking at the need to
make society stricter now we're talking
about protecting children you know that
there are 10 000 unaccompanied minors
who've gone missing in europe
and now we're hearing from child focus
that since the beginning of the war
in ukraine
2
000 miners are missing where are they
that is underplayed
it is our duty to look for those
children
we know that they're fleeing we know
that they're in another european country
in poland
i hope that they are safe
but i fear that some of them are dead
it is the proof of society how it deals
with weak people so let's show
who we are we're
late we need to register we need to make
sure that they get child-friendly
information we have to make sure that
they're looked after we have to make
sure that their parents are found that
is our duty
we have european instruments let us beef
them up
the passion for this debate that we have
if we were living in ukraine
if it were our children who were on the
run
don't you want people to protect them
yes i won't i have two children let's
protect the children and i want to
conclude
with a sitat of a great woman madeleine
albright
the bottom line
is that the person who flees his or her
home
does not shed the right
to be treated with dignity and respect
thank you very much
thank you very much miss vautmans and
now on behalf of the greens group
saskiabrigmo
what's up
maybe it's not children that are being
targeted but it's children who are being
killed
and this underscores the cruelty of war
violence exile for the youngest
any life that's held in suspension is a
life that's being stolen
and being thrown into
danger being thrown into fear this is
something that children should not have
to experience and children are
the
victims the first victims
of atrocities that adults are
committing and at least 158 have paid
with their lives this must stop
almost two million children are all
already
fleeing war 60 percent of the population
ukraine is internally displaced and some
people who have remained live in
constant fear of the ongoing conflict
the european union is taking its
responsibility it's acted rapidly to
implement the directive on temporary
protection there has to be
quick and speedy support
for those fleeing ukraine without any
distinction
we have to make sure the most vulnerable
are protected so that we don't add to
the horrors of war discrimination and
affecting their dignity in that way
we have to make sure that official
transports after they cross borders to
make sure we avoid exploitation and
abuse and trafficking of children we
need to provide the support they need
the needs they need we have to find a
tutor that's appointed immediately for
these unaccompanied children and trying
to achieve family reunification we have
to allow these children and teenagers to
have prospects of a future of a
dignified fashion we have to reopen
the possibility to have access to child
guarantee
and to education if they have access to
education culture psycho
social support
and sexual reproductive health and
rights that is extremely important their
association civil society organizations
local authorities as well who have acted
in exemplary fashion you are the face of
europe welcoming people and let us make
us proud of the solidarity we've shown
that your actions and voices have called
for for so many years it is now time to
put human and financial resources at the
direct disposal of the organizations
local authorities and citizens who are
showing solidarity who shouldn't have to
show this entire burden themselves yes
there are things being put in place to
help people fleeing ukraine
but this shows that european solidarity
works what we're
implementing today has to provide a
pillar a common pillar that
common asylum and migration policy in
europe is built on on welcoming on
solidarity on being humane and this
appeal is one of the vast majority of
this chamber following close cooperation
between the different political groups
thank you colleagues thank you
for to the ukrainian youth and the youth
of europe as well
thank you for colleague
thank you very much
our next speaker is miss
simona baldessari
thank you very much colleagues
every minute
a child becomes a refugee in ukraine
that's what unicef said a few days ago
many children have completely lost
the basis of their life they've grown up
very fast
either they've become refugees or
they're
shut up in various
cellars
or shelters
about two million
children have left ukraine in the hope
of finding a better future
we in the european union need to take
action
many of these children risk being
exposed to trafficking in human beings
when they enter the european union we
must immediately register and identify
these children
and if we've got children that they are
com that are accompanied we must see who
they're traveling with we have to see
what their needs are and if they need
health
services or if they
need psychological help they should get
it there are also
orphans who are in the middle of this
war
there are babies who've been born in
bunkers and shelters during the war it's
a tragedy we've got to help these
children we've got to set up
humanitarian corridors so they can reach
the eu safely that those are some of the
main points in our report
it'll be positive to include all
political groups in this work these are
children who should not be exposed to
ideological wars let's stand shoulder to
shoulder and ensure that these children
have a future if we're to get peace on
earth if we want to combat war we've got
to start with the children thank you
[Music]
um
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
mothers are being
raped
and
children
abused
mothers
uh fleeing from ukraine to the
closest safe haven
this safe haven
turned out to be
poland
in the last
weeks over two and a half million
ukrainians
fled to poland
it is
polish people that
received
ukrainians some 160 000 children
now have access to polish educational
system
we have provided
all
rights healthcare and otherwise
we appeal to create a fund
to
finance
all the costs
we have received over two and a half
refugees two and a half million refugees
what funds have we
received
you are so emotional
and saying that it's so horrible we must
begin to act
and
we should stop with appearances
we need
decisive sanctions we're talking about
genocide
and the violation of
basic human rights
and
what is the union
doing sanctioning poland who received
two and a half million refugees
uh the funds that we should receive
uh
are being blocked
uh but of course uh remember
uh the annexation of the crimea
and the embargo on exports of arms to
russia
how many
european
member states
violated those sanctions this embargo 10
and
the current sanctions are equally
ineffective
so
they
uh
women
first violated uh uh
later
run over by tanks
and it is not only a war
against ukraine
it is a war
against the west
a war against the world as a whole if we
are talking about human rights
they are being violated because the
sanctions
are not real
canadians
miss cornelia ernst is the next speaker
yeah
ladies and gentlemen maybe this could be
a good day if we have a resolution on
the table
that doesn't just talk about promising
humanitarian aid in its
headline but in its context as well
because in war
young people and children often without
any protection all of them
and that's why it's right that we talk
about roma children stateless children
young students
but also especially vulnerable people
like lgbti people
should be included in protected from
violence because butcher has shown us
clearly
that people who go around killing others
don't ask for their id cards first so
support our amendments so children and
young people who are in prison and
detention centers
in
ukraine most of these being third
country national should not be forgotten
children are children regardless of
where they come from and that's why i
call on you to stop speaking with a fork
tongue here
because protecting people in ukraine
should be a priority protecting children
that is absolutely
clear and i stand behind that
but to
condemn people to
rotting in prison because they come from
another country is not acceptable we
don't want ideologies and racism now we
want selfless help
to show what a society really can
achieve and in these sort of times
equality and freedom are
values that nobody should ignore
and hence the support of all fleeing
children is necessary
all of those who are on the external
borders of the eu especially thank you
thank you
thank you
i'll ask
now ms daniela rondinelli to come to the
lectern
grazia
thank you very much president
commissioner dear colleagues since the
beginning of the war four million
refugees from ukraine have streamed into
the eu
and that includes one million miners who
we're talking about today
we're talking about their entry into
europe and all the actions that we're
establishing in order to welcome them
and in order to safeguard their rights
as we've said their rights are
fundamental
i would like to put the focus on a
problem which is dear to my heart it's
the fact that all of these young people
all of these students
are
breaking off their studies
they're no longer able to train
if we want to truly protect these young
people who are fleeing from war then we
need to go above and beyond simply
welcoming them and hosting them we need
to work on integration we need to have
humanitarian teaching corridors and
other mechanisms of solidarity so that
young people teachers and students from
ukraine can enter our schools
we must do everything in our power
to ensure that dialogue happens and
to do
more
working together uh hand in hand with
ukrainian students in ukrainian
universities
there needs to be a right to continued
schooling and university for
ukrainians and for others who want to
arrive in europe we could have an
extraordinary program
erasmus for ukraine
erasmus ukraine would allow students to
sign up for free
this year
and it would
it would establish a waiver
for
learning
uh for
those teachers who are currently in the
war
diplomas would be recognized
as
and this would be of
this will be extremely important for uh
young ukrainian people so that they can
reconstruct and help the renaissance of
their country what's always been so good
about our policies is that we have been
able to bring people together and to
build wealth and prosperity together
thank you
okay
thank you very much miss zabina
now
can take the floor
president
thank you very much president
commissioners
the european union is based on the
belief that war
on the continent of europe has been
consigned to history unfortunately mr
putin has destroyed this
the attack of putin on ukraine involves
attacks on civilians
women and children these attacks are
happening on schools theaters and
hospitals and this is an attack on our
very values in europe and as a crime
against humanity the russian invasion in
ukraine is not just threatening the
population but threatening the future of
a whole generation many people fleeing
our children and need
in need of a special protection we have
to make sure these people get protection
and access to education so they have a
future regardless of where they have to
flee to otherwise in the longer term we
risk a lost generation
children need special protection from
any form of violence or abuse and we
have to
take care of children
schools are extremely important for the
physical and mental and psychological
health of those children who've had to
leave their home country psychosocial
support and as a
safe environment is what children who
have been traumatized need and it is
our obligation to do our utmost to make
sure that we provide help for these
children and
enable a future to be one of their
prospects that they can see so we need
to make sure they have access to
education at all levels psychosocial
support for traumatized children support
for undercover need children and young
people including stateless
people
and that means the eu needs to make sure
that the member states
support us in getting access to erasmus
and other programs this shouldn't just
be something that we think of as
part-time it's an obligation as human
beings yeah
thank you very much
now
miss gabriela bischoff has the flaw
thank you president commissioner ladies
and gentlemen
this
war
is having an effect on the entire
generation of children in ukraine but
also
on a whole generation of children and
young people in europe who see how we're
dealing with this war and with refugee
children and young people
and therefore it's important
the seven and a half million
children and young people in ukraine
need help they need psychosocial support
and that's why it's important that we're
having this discussion
and i think it's absolutely horrific
that the council is not here obviously
the debate is not of sufficient interest
to them
as smd
we have already called on the council to
adopt a child protection
package
and it's important that we do that again
who protects these children if we don't
do it as mr johansson said we must first
and foremost
treat these child refugees as children
it sounds easy but it isn't and that's
why we need special
measures and that's why education is so
important we have to make sure that we
have inclusive action
access rather that we give digital
support to these children
we have to make sure that there's child
care available so the women can enter
the labor market
exploitation of these children
and
women is a huge risk we see that the
international
networks of traffickers of human beings
are on the spot
we can be proud in europe that we have
the child guarantee but we must give it
a fresh coat of paint we have to adapt
it to this situation and that means
financing because one thing is clear
i've said that from the beginning at the
end of the day we will be
measured
according to whether or not we could
protect these children in the war and we
as in the european parliament do our
utmost to make sure that they find
safety
thank you very much the next speaker is
mr petrus austrovicious
mr chair
your commissioners
colleagues
the war of aggression launched by the
putin regime against ukraine is
primarily directed towards ukrainian
civilians especially women and children
the brutal and criminal acts of putin's
war amount to ethnic cleansing and
genocide
putin is seeking to expel ukrainians
from their homeland to seize their land
and property
atrocious war crimes committed by
russian soldiers increasingly threaten
the security and livelihoods of
ukrainian people
the russian aggressors seek to impede
the evacuation of civilians oftentimes
by taking advantage of humanitarian
corridors in order to force the
resettlements of ukrainians to russia
the u.n refugee
agency must facilitate the safe return
of all ukrainian refugees
i sincerely do not understand we
strongly question
the agreements made by the head of the
red cross peter maurer
during his visit to moscow to open
refugee camps in russia
can we allow this de facto human
trafficking
ukrainian refugees especially children
and young adults should not become
a lost generation
deprived of the happy childhood and the
chance
of the of an education
we must do everything we can to ensure
the future of peaceful ukrainian caught
up in the uh putin's war
it is also important that ukrainian
children receive an education without
losing their cultural identity and
language
ukrainians are in need of safe refuge
we must now behave as europeans
and welcome
all of them into our family into our
union thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
to next speakers alice kunker for two
and a half minutes
president commissioners ladies and
gentlemen
i've just got back from ukraine and
poland
together with polish volunteers i
visited an area north west of la viv
in javeli of a small town
ukraine's future
is fleeing
in the villages around the population
have doubled tripled even in terms of
number of people many children
who have been fleeing are fleeing within
their own country putin's bombs have
forced millions of children to flee and
to leave their homes behind them
those who should be sitting safely in
their school benches or playing in their
kindergartens instead are left in
uncertainty
teenage rooms have been exchanged for
camp beds in transit
camps
playgrounds have been exchanged for
metro stations to
work as bunkers
these people fleeing have their first
experience of the eu the people they
meet at the border and
there's a lot of people received with
warmth with blankets a bit of chocolate
but the polish
authorities nor eu resources were often
not to be found and whoever could have
not had any difficulty in finding these
people who were tired and exploited them
at another border station there were
children who had frozen to death who
died of
of lack of water in their parents in
mostly mother's arms
they're trafficking leagues that are
there to pick up chil women before
they've even left ukraine
and pick them up once they cross the
border i saw testimonies where women
were
obliged to pay their access with sex no
should nobody should be exposed to that
no child should have to experience that
the eu has to eradicate men buying sex
men buying women and children how
ridiculous is that how sick is that who
is kidnapping children who has sex with
children who buys women who are fleeing
who've lost everything
it's those men who have a special place
in hell
the eu has resources they have
responsibility after these days however
in poland and ukraine i'm worried that
our big words about how horrible this is
will not be followed by actions by deeds
it is a
nightmare what we saw
but that we didn't do everything we
could would be awful thank you
thank you
thank you very much
now mr jean-paul gerrard has the floor
the conflict in
ukraine is upending the whole world the
scenes of devastation
are increasing in number there are more
and more victims the people are
affected very hard particularly women
and children who are fleeing they leave
their houses behind they separate
themselves from their husbands who have
been left to defend the country it is
unacceptable that such a tragedy is
unfolding on the european continent
given this
given these scenes there has been
solidarity great humanity people have
spurred themselves into action we must
further encourage all initiatives at all
levels which provide support to these
unfortunate people the remarkable
countries on the list includes poland
two and a half million
refugees have been taken in romania
hungary and there are others too it's
the best of a europe of nations we must
support all of those countries but
they're not being supported it's quite
the opposite it's stunning to see that
while there is solidarity no european
aid has reached these countries i've
mentioned but what's even worse is that
the european court of justice and the
european commission have
taken sanctions against hungary and
poland they are criticized of breaking
the rule of law but i think that is a
questionable allegation
these are different issues but it's
shocking we see that there is solidarity
but
the commission doesn't support poland
and hungary the commission
has provided it has
has stopped 39.4
million euros from reaching poland and
seven million euros from reaching
hungary these countries are exemplary in
their solidarity showing solidarity to
millions of refugees but they are being
punished by our institutions these
countries must not be sanctioned no they
must be helped and congratulated
the
commission found the funds to deal with
the health crisis to sanction russia and
to find money for weapons for ukraine
the the commission should also provide
support for poland and hungary it should
start by lifting sanctions and allowing
them to have access to european funds
maybe the commission doesn't like the
political systems in those countries but
i am very scandalized by the fact that
the left and the liberals in this
country are putting pressure on the
commission so that the commission
wouldn't make 39.4 billion euros
available to poland the socialists and
the democrats the greens the
the left and the s d
on the 24th of march
spoke to the commission about that and i
think that is wrong
the european commission must unblock the
recovery funds and provide additional
support so that these millions of
refugees these vulnerable people can be
protected they are vulnerable to many
threats thank you
see
our next speech thank you
robert sielen
commissioners
the best way to protect children and
youth from ukraine would be to
adopt very strong sanctions this week
relating to energy so that we do not
keep feeding the war machinery of russia
of course we will hope for such
sanctions but there are very many young
people who already are here in the
european union some in some states more
and some less and mo many of them are
under the risk of criminal
activities of criminal bans
so we need integration that of course is
a very delicate um
thing
about integrating the youths and
children countries where they end up
that is because it is very important
also to keep up the ukrainian space of
culture and education for these
youngsters and it is very important
there are countries
like latvia for example where is there
is still a russian education available
in state countries and if we will send
the ukrainian kids to these schools it
would end up in in uh
not with good results because there of
course the narrative also arrives not
only from the state means but also from
the russian propaganda and that would be
very dangerous for the this ukrainian
generation so therefore they would have
to have this
um
this link kept with their own identity
with the ukrainian language that means
we have to support the local
local municipalities so that they could
improve uh
the situation and create such ukrainian
schools ukrainian language um
space
and we could
also use
editions from all kinds of
companies like anak they have
study books and i would believe that
most of these children and
youth will return to ukraine provided
they have a respective education here
thank you
thank you
for marlene burke
city
thank you
four million people almost have fled
from putin's
horrible war most are children
and women and they're particularly
exposed as we know from all refugee
situations
and the best time that we can support
them is as they cross the border so
we've got to focus there
so that they're not
caught up with traffickers and other
people who want to expose of what to
exploit rather the situation of women
and children we know that voluntary
organizations are doing a lot of work on
the ground so there must be support for
them and for the local authorities
children should be able to go to school
they should be have the freedom to move
and do sport and it's important for us
to ensure that that happens
and i want to say something about the
fact that women and young girls are
exploited
sexually we see that in
all
refugee situations and we
need to deal with that at the border we
also need to make sure that we don't
have a sex ed industry in europe
we have these sex industries which
exploit
vulnerable women and girls without any
control we've got to do our utmost to
stop this we've got a terrible situation
we've got millions of children
fleeing when this shows the racism of
the eu's refugee policy
a lot of us are very happy to see that
we're now
wanting to care for these refugees but
we should do the same for all other
children who are refugees we shouldn't
lock them up in
refugee camps in greece or anywhere else
children should be able to go to school
and should be able to be free and that
applies to all children thank you
i thought
thank you miss andre
kasana
thank you very much mr president
children are our future that's why we
have to be extremely careful that in
these difficult times
we can provide safety for children more
than 4.8 million people to date have
fled
about half of them are children and
young people who
require
an extra degree of care
they need to be able to find safe refuge
in eu member states and it's extremely
important whenever when it becomes
possible that they can return
but until then they should be allowed to
attend school
hungary to date
has
taken in at 400 000 refugees and we're
doing
everything we can to ensure these people
are safe
and ensure they have access to health
and psychosociological
support
and of course that they get lessons in
school
we
have also introduced hungarian
conversation classes in
afternoons in universities
we have to pay attention to
those children who come unaccompanied
in ukraine there are also many displaced
persons we have to make sure that our
help reaches them too
i can imagine that the eu should set up
a program
whereby
these children these families be fed and
provided for in
ukraine in the transcarpathian region
there are more than 300 000 refugees
who've arrived
about
400 children are orphans
and they are particularly vulnerable
so we have to do our utmost to help
these children
thank you chairman millions of people
have left ukraine
they've fled the
war crimes the putin and the bombs and
we've seen in butcher what these women
were of what these people were exposed
to before they fled and what has
happened to the people who stayed behind
90
of refugees are women and children
children who should be able to be
children who should be able to go to
school
to play freely
and we've said this before
it's lovely to see
how
all of europe
is standing together and how
refugees however
volunteers are helping
how we see
prams made available at stations for
fleeing mothers how children share their
toys i'm very proud of this solidarity
which is being seen in europe at the
moment
but
we need action to maintain this
wave of solidarity because that is a big
challenge and continue to be a big
challenge we need to stand together
to
help refugees we have to make sure that
the budget is there so the children have
access to health care education and
psychosocial
support we need to protect
children
against trafficking
by these criminal gangs who are always
looking to make it take advantage of
vulnerable people
we need to focus on the most
vulnerable refugees and we need to have
proper registration of refugees so
nobody's lost
why
while we're bringing our children to
school
well wrapped up against the cold
ukrainian mothers are writing essential
information on the backs of their
children hoping that somebody will look
after them
we've got to do our utmost to those
children to make sure that those
children as well can just be children
thank you very much
mr len
you have to flow
thank you very much mr president
commissioners
when in maripol the theater was bombed
there was a little girl
who was
hidden under the concrete and the dust
miraculously she survived
but she hasn't spoken a word since then
the war in ukraine is a brutal war
against
our children in the middle of march we
social democrats therefore
issued important demands to protect
children who are affected by war
and so
i and we are very pleased that we're
looking at a resolution concerning
children now no child ever should have
to experience a war anywhere ever all
children have rights to a safe childhood
and when it comes to the response of the
eu to the war in ukraine we social
democrats demand
that the
convention on the rights of the child
that all eu member states have signed be
respected and implemented the best
for children as we have said on many
occasions has to be
respected in any decision concerning
children hence i welcome commissioner
ilva yuwansan's very clear statement
that we are to ensure that children be
registered in a correct
fashion at the borders we should see all
children
we have to bolster our work in the eu to
prevent the risks of abuse
the needs for children the simple needs
of
clean water food psychosocial support
and safe places to
both rest and to play plus education
must be prioritized children don't just
have a right to survive they also have a
right to safety development education
and play all children have the same
rights and the same values
we are to do our utmost to ensure
the human rights of these children and
that we actually live up to our
responsibilities thank you
[Music]
madame
thank you very much
some have died
under the bombs and will never become
adults
some
were born inside and have not yet seen
the light of day some were in school and
their schools were bombed they've been
separated from their parents
they've been forced to go to russia
there are those who have fled they are
the children of ukraine ukraine europe
has opened its arms to them but every
day we must ask ourselves are we doing
enough for the children of ukraine
let me say something we must do much
much more
more for those who are still in ukraine
and
who don't have enough don't have enough
supplies we need more humanitarian aid
because dogs are being eaten in mario
paul we must exert greater pressure on
musk on moscow so that there can be more
evacuations of women and children we
must support moldova which has a record
number of inhabitants one hundred
thousand in that country which just has
two and a half million people
half of those
who have been hosted are children
i
want to know what is going to happen
next how we're going to ensure that all
refugees receive support moldovan
families have opened their houses and
are sharing everything they have i want
to ask donors how will you support kids
now
which is doing its best i asked member
state members i asked member states to
ensure that the poor poorest country in
europe not be left to shoulder this
burden alone one final word about
the children of ukraine and their
mothers
some of these children
were born from
um surrogacy
or from ivf
and some have been asking how is this
even possible in ukraine that there be
surrogacy allowed well if you're in
favor of life then you're in favour of
all lives i hope that these mothers and
these children
will be welcomed in europe as they ought
to be welcomed warmly and with humanity
thank you
thank you
thank you very much
mrs diana
you know you have the floor
thank you president
commissioner
the war in ukraine has already led to
thousands of civilian deaths including
young people and children it has forced
more than 4 million people to flee and
to seek out protection in europe
of those 4 million 2 million are still
of schooling age
according to unicef 90
of refugees are boys girls and women
various ngos tell us that there are many
non-accompanied minors among the
refugees they are particularly
vulnerable to trafficking abuse and
sexual exploitation
it is of the utmost importance that we
protect all of these boys and girls
and we ensure that their rights are
safeguarded including from a gender
perspective
that's why the work of unicef and the
unhcr is so vital that work is being
done together with
governments and civil society
organizations on the border in the
border areas they are creating blue dot
hubs these are safe spaces along border
crossings for girls boys and women
the devastating consequences of this war
won't be resolved in the immediate term
we need foresight we need a broader
approach to implement integration and
hosting policies at national
at regional and local level that
includes access to education and to the
labor market it includes family
reunification psychosocial support and
access to basic services
it's not just lives that are being lost
its futures too
we must ensure that the conditions are
in place so that in europe all boys and
girls fleeing from war
can
find themselves in a peaceful and safe
environment which they deserve
they should be allowed to go back to the
classroom the eu needs to be a place
where they can imagine a future for
themselves thank you very much
thank you flams belong has always said
that the right to asylum is a basic
human right on two conditions first of
all we really got to be talking about
war refugees and they've got to be
received in their own region
we have can expect up to 12 million
women and children fleeing ukraine who
need support
there is a big wave of solidarity across
all parties but we shouldn't be
too
[Music]
um
we
shouldn't be
shouldn't hide the fact that we can't
deal with this
if we to continue the asylum
policy we have the moment we've had
millions of young
men who've come in to europe two thirds
of them were
refused because they were not really as
refugees they were looking for an
economic improvement
we've got to be a
real we have to have realism and have a
proper asylum
policy
so we've got to suspend
at the asylum policy for those people
who are not of ukrainian nationality
because we've got to expose to keep this
for the
people who needed most ukrainian
children so we've got to deal with
asylum seekers from out with europe and
send them back as soon as possible
because most of them
are
not really
in need of asylum
we've got to make sure that we support
the citizens of ukraine with funds from
the european union
we can help a lot more people in our
neighboring countries
then in
places
which have a
high population density like flanders
hungary and poland are hosting 3 million
they're so often criticized but they're
doing a great job and we need to support
them we need to shift to another
asylum policy which works we've got to
host people in their own
africans should be in africa asians in
asia and europeans in europe thank you
commissioners
we expected problems
from russia we warned
for years
we
asked you to provide security for this
part of europe even a few days before
the war
we were told that the eu
will not take would not take care of
this security problem
you want to engage into cooperation
with russia even more are you going to
say the same to the mario paul children
today poland has received over a million
children
what do they need
they need most of all
um peace they need more efforts from the
eu or maybe the french presidency
or more gestures like president metzolas
we need to cooperate with
the ukrainian authorities we need to
register
those
who
have crossed the border
as a teacher
i would like to focus on the issue of
education we need european funds
for the transportation and evacuation of
those children we need to provide them
language learning
we need to have new
books for these children which would
integrate
curricula that taught in ukrainian and
in polish schools
we need teachers we need psychologists
dealing with integration and cultural
um with cultural integration
we need special scholarship programs
but also programs
of care for the youngest so that the
mothers can work thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
miss katarina connecticut has
[Music]
dear commissioners i will support
the protected children
resolution
because they are the weakest in the war
and deserve protection
uh nevertheless uh this resolution
um central europe poland czech republic
slovakia romania
they accept a huge number of
refugees
even compared to the 2015 standards
poland accepted about two million
refugees
uh but uh germany only one and a half
million
back in 2015 and it's a much bigger
country why i'm saying this because this
is a big burden on the systems of a
healthcare system for education and so
on
we should honor these countries
people offer their homes to
refugees without any funds from
anybody else
and this should be mentioned in the
resolution
the resolution speaks about what members
they should do without mentioning what
they already have done
in the ukraine
we have a lot of people with rare
diseases and about 13 as much patients
with hiv
and
that basically means that we have like
between 13 and 16 000
new cancer patients a month
also the children need vaccinations and
we need hundreds of thousands of life
vaccinations which need to be produced
colleagues you have to help us now
otherwise our healthcare systems will
collapse please help us help us with
beds and help us with healthcare
materials
show solidarity in your acts thank you
very much
thank you
thank you very much
mr lefteris nikolao alavanos please
the russian invasion
and
the war
also a result of nato
eu
us involvement
has led to
refugees
thousands millions of refugees many of
whom are children and this is a terrible
situation we must take all
people
into our countries without there being
any criteria we as the greek communist
party are
supporters of refugees and we must do
everything to help them
people must be
welcomed
with humane conditions and we need to
provide education for young children
all children and refugees must be
welcomed into our countries that
includes migrant children russian
speaking children and others who may
have worked or lived in
ukrainia in ukraine we must be in line
with all of the criteria in the geneva
convention it's so important that the eu
and all eu member states and all eu
member state governments
look also at what's happening in libya
syria and other countries and treat
those countries the same because
currently we have a state of hypocrisy
and
we shouldn't just think that ukrainians
fit in better because they look more
similar to us
and in addition
we shouldn't think that just because
they have a similar creed to us and then
uh other refugees are at risk of being
oppressed or turned away or they are put
in terrible cramps such as
such as on lesbos or moria and there are
huge mega structures for them now we
should
not forget that all of these children
are the victims of terrible wars support
needs to be provided their rights need
to be safeguarded and so on
it's also important
that we withdraw ourselves from military
alliances and we fight for the interest
of the people against the system the
system which brings about war and which
then leads to exploitation thank you
thank you
the next speaker is mr thomas frankowski
the russian invasion not only threatens
ukraine and its people
but also threatens an entire generation
some
half of
the refugees are young people so we need
to give them access to education
children fleeing ukraine are
helpless
so
teachers should be
well prepared to
work with such traumatized children
and to ensure
access quick access to education we
should use
online platforms used in the pandemic
we must ensure that young
children and adolescents from
ukraine
continue
uh their education so school education
gateway
could be a good way to proceed
we must also
not re uh forget uh ukrainian
students that are the future
of ukraine and i am pleased to say that
many member states
offered
grants
to those students we should also
recognize
uh qualifications of chil of teachers
and
health workers
because this will also help children in
their new in the
states of uh
receiving them
sport is also
important
and
those children should have access to
sport activities
because this can
help them
psychologically to overcome their
traumas
this will also help them integrate
this is our common uh responsibility to
make sure that these children
feel safe and have a future
thank you
thank you experienceable
thank you very much
refugees
our people who are fleeing
hunger or war these are men women and
children they all need security and
stability
they need secure
routes for fleeing particularly
children and their families the war in
ukraine is just outside our front door
and then it requires us to do our utmost
to receive
refugees and we're seeing civil society
cities and local authorities throughout
europe
are prepared to help her we've got to
recognize that
and
the commission must
give these organizations these cities
and local authorities access to eu funds
and
rapidly
having said that it's not just up to
civil society to receive refugees from
ukraine this applies particularly to
unaccompanied minors we have to have
clear
state structures to ensure the welfare
of children the commission and the
member states must rapidly
find and ensure that there is a
safe transport of refugees
particularly in the context of family
unification the solidarity
platform and the index for analyzing the
capacity to receive refugees are a good
first step towards this
and after that they have to be specific
steps taken to distribute the refugees
who need our help
after the decision of
temporary protection the council which
unfortunately is absent today has to
take the next step to ensure that the
families and children get the support
and the protection they need
thank you colleague
i now give the floor to miss tune and
hon stein
good that such a vast majority present
in this room agrees
i host three children and minors
from eastern ukraine
for over a month now
they are accompanied they go to polish
schools and kindergarten they are in our
warm and safe home
and still
the three years old arthur chick tells
me with wide open eyes
why are they shooting at my daddy
you know
bad people evil people are shooting at
my daddy why
scars will remain
and yes
we all must undertake all that is
possible to make them bearable
and to put an end to this horror
commissioner dubravka suicia stressed
all children have a right to a happy and
normal childhood
all
so let us struggle for all of them
the prolongation of the ukrainian polish
border is the border between poland and
belorus belo russia
it's the same line
it is also our schengen border
and there
in the forests and swamps
for months already
families with children are pushed back
mistreated freezing starving dying
their only fault is that they are from
central asia most of them
those volunteers who struggle to save
their lives
are not awarded with high distinctions
but are accused of human trafficking
the prosecution demanded their arrest
please let us not divide humans let us
not divide children into categories
please remember also those at the belo
russian border thank you
okay
thank you very much
the next speaker is miss katrin
langensiepen
when the war started in ukraine my first
thought was what happens to the 2.7
millions of persons with disabilities in
that war
what does war mean from a perspective of
a child with disabilities
in ukraine live 82 000 children with
disabilities
it might be more
when your parents are afraid and you
cannot flee what does it mean to you
when you are a wheelchair user how is it
possible for you to go down in a bomb
seller with your parents or not
how do you know that's an alarm when you
can't hear the sirens and your parents
are there
i contacted a disability ngo in kiev i
asked him what do you need
answer everything but the most is
attention
no one cares about us about persons and
children with disabilities there's no
access to transport there's no access to
information no access to accessible
shelters and how do we know how
accessible the places where the families
with disabled children need to go
is there a accessible shelter in poland
is there a interpreter for deaf people
for me as a deaf person
i don't know so i stay in kiev
nevertheless if the bombs are there or
not when we want to support ngos
structures and support children with
disabilities we must be sure that the
money goes for into
accessible direction must be used for
accessibility
we have to offer accessible health care
accessible shelters accessible education
personal assistance interpreters inside
the european union in our member states
i call the commission
you
and member states to take the uncrpd
article 7 into account
with written
in all actions concerning children with
disabilities the best interests of the
child shall be a primary consideration
thank you
[Applause]
thank you for colleagues
thank you colleague the next speaker is
mr guido heil
hey president
president ladies and gentlemen
i have traveled to ukraine with
humanitarian aid and i saw a country in
the group of fear
i saw men who are prepared to do
anything to defend their country i've
seen women and children fleeing
and obviously they're exposed to danger
and
need protection
we have the traffickers in human p
beings ready to
take people into prostitution or in
dealing in organs but we also need
protection
protect them against
young
men from asia and africa who have mixed
in with this exodus and
are exposing
using
this
crisis
there were women who were raped by a
tunisian
and an afghan in germany and they had to
flee back to poland because they didn't
feel safe in germany
i have
refugees that starting with it's a young
woman
a young woman with
a baby and she's only been
a month in
germany and she's already
working in a
hotel and catering we have to decide
whether we want to help real refugees or
just economic migrants who've come in
with
no papers
they've left children and families
behind in their country of origin
and then they abuse our hospitality
i want to make
way i want to make space for real
refugees i want to release funds for
real refugees for women and children
thank you
so
i now give the floor to mr richard
chaneski
president commissioners ladies and
gentlemen
do not ask for for whom the bell tolls
it tolls for you this is our tragedy
because um
ukraine is a part of europe so this is a
tragedy of europe
and it's not
an exotic matter it is also our
responsibility
we cannot
just watch it without doing anything we
should pass from words to to these
because of course it's easy to talk
about solidarity about support and much
more difficult to
do concrete things to provide concrete
help to these people
both to the internally displaced people
in ukraine around seven million people
and to
this huge wave of refugees over two
million people
70
of those have come to mind my country
to poland two and a half million
of course it's easy to say on behalf of
the european parliament we are providing
help we are helping but these beautiful
words should be followed by financial
decisions for the moment
this is much more difficult for the
moment um the aid to the country's
receiving uh
refugees is only symbolic
and i do agree with um ms zippel
who said
that it's not only a matter for this um
for the civil society yes of course
civil society plays an important part
and the so the financial support should
also reach uh
those member states
and then the matter of the hybrid war
on the belarussian
border
let's um watch this situation and let's
help the refugees thank you very much
and i'll give the floor to mr over
already more than a month the war in
ukraine has been going on the russian
aggression in the ukraine is destroying
human lives destroying their property
chasing many of them from their homes of
course the
those who suffer the most are the
children there are 3.7 million refugees
out of the ukraine on the move now 90
percent of those are women and children
i would like to thank all member states
helping these people to reach safety to
find provisional shelters of course the
children are the most vulnerable here
and that is why the european parliament
wants to adopt this resolution what is
most important is the creation of
humanitarian corridors for granting safe
passage to people who are fleeing the
war i'm very sorry and i'm not seeing
any representative of the french
presidency here today we should be
hearing we sh we should be told what the
french president has done with his
mandate in order to help precisely these
children these people who need to get
out of
besieged cities such as mariopol and
others i'm sure you've also seen the sad
eyes of ukrainian children becoming
happier all of a sudden when they reach
a group of their peers when they can
kick a ball around where they can ride a
bike again
children are the future of ukraine
children are the future of the eu and
all that we do here and now for
ukrainian children we are also doing for
ourselves for europe
children with their mothers need to find
accommodation health care psychological
help
and of course education
in this regard
i would like to commend the
work done by member states and the
commission we have the solidarity
platform we have the registration
platform we are making sure that
children don't get lost we are making
sure that
we have educational platforms to help
exchange good practice information
between member states
i would like to thank once more the
member states helping i would like to
thank all volunteers let's make sure
that not a single child gets lost that
not a single child is without aid i
would also like to remind everybody that
the czech republic is hosting three
hundred thousand refugees and is also
helping thank you
thank you
i now give the floor to miss youngarius
thank you president commissioners
in recent days we've seen horrific
images from ukraine
meeting our eyes
and we saw
wasted towns cities villages raised to
the ground children and women on the
streets almost 4 million ukrainian
refugees
have left ukraine
and half of them are children we can't
leave them in the lurch
they need more than just nice words than
just lip service
they need even more than just a nice
resolution from the european parliament
they need our support at our action
because outside the
theater of war there are still huge
risks poverty exclusion ex and
exploitation
are
lying in weight within the european
union as well and so a speedy targeted
form of action is necessary
the european social pillar
is very clear social inclusion and
protection are crucial
and the urgency of the porto
goals
is just becoming more and more evident
in porto we said we're going to fight
poverty we're going to make inclusion
possible
it must be time to deliver now europe
has to speak with one voice and say that
we have not forgotten the ukrainian
children
they have to have appropriate education
accommodation good care
they have to have appropriate
help and care for social and
psychological support
we have to show that we're willing to
invest in the future of the ukrainian
children and that we can provide
structural help as well because europe
being a safe refuge doesn't mean that we
just pay lip service to it we have to
act as well
[Music]
thank you very much i now give the floor
to mr dragosh bislaru
thank you chair
dear vice president schwitzer dear
commissioner johansson
honorable colleagues
this weekend we all saw the atrocities
committed by vladimir putin's armies
against civilian zombuja
these crimes are yet
another reminder of russia's willingness
to attack innocent people
and act against the international law
and it is our duty to step up our
actions to help ukraine and its
civilians seeking security within our
union
our duty is only increased by the fact
that the majority of ukrainian refugees
entering europe are vulnerable children
and young people i've seen them with my
own eyes at the border of between
romania and ukraine i've seen them
together with commissioner nikola
schmidt when visiting a transit facility
in pleist
women and children with their eyes in
tears
as we welcome the first necessary tools
introduced by the introduced by the
commission the temporary protection
directives and the care care plus
packages
we should use the resilience of our
social security systems to receive these
children in the best conditions
protecting children fleeing from war is
a right we must fulfill in their best
interest away from any discrimination we
must protect them from the other dangers
present on the way to europe violence
exploitation abuse trafficking and
abduction dangers we will not want our
children to encounter and this is not
only about the refugees the children
coming from ukraine
also about protecting vulnerable people
in general this is about the social
resilience of the european union this is
about the child guarantee about the
european pillar of social rights about
not leaving people behind
this is the reality that we need to be
there for vulnerable people
generally speaking and together with the
member states civil societies and
volunteers we should not give up on
ukraine let's continue working together
towards a safer europe where innocent
disadvantaged children and citizens are
protected where the images seen this
weekend should not be seen again thank
you
thank you
thank you very much mr pizzaroo
child
president commissioners
colleagues we are in a serious
unprecedented
child protection crisis and it's of an
enormous scale the brutality inflicted
on ukraine in places like bucca marie
apollodesa and kharkiv are war crimes
murder torture rape
death adults brutalized and traumatized
imagine what it is like as a child
just imagine this is the devastation for
you of ukraine for all of us to see
children separated from their families
as families are torn apart their
security gone
strange places strange journeys new
countries new languages this is the
traumatization of a generation the
shattering of the security of childhood
colleagues every sanction must be used
by us and our partners around the world
and as they perpetrate such crimes
against every generation
russia must cease to be a member of the
un human rights council this is life and
death with access to food safety
education and psychosocial support all
immediate needs for children the fate of
a generation is at stake and we must
help them and we are helping firstly we
also have to be vigilant for traffickers
in every dire situation there is someone
who seeks to profit our police must be
at the top of their game the
coordination must be excellent
secondly we must ensure the children's
right to education is not interrupted
these months while these children are
displaced and in other countries must
not be the ones where they just survive
but where they thrive thirdly warm beds
and safe houses are what make children
feel secure many are traumatized already
parents particularly mothers need care
need support so that they can get back
on their feet we must also embrace
unaccompanied minors being alone in the
world at such a young age can you
imagine it one of the most terrifying
things you can possibly imagine
our actions today can empower those who
will build ukraine again it is our duty
to help them now
thank you
thank you
very much
um
mr massimilianos
thank you president
almost three million
young people
are in dire need
only 47 000 have actually had access to
educational material or to recreational
material
not enough
there are students
who are particularly affected by this
war
now it's up to the member states to deal
with this challenge they need to bring
young people into their education and
training systems by providing
specialized training to those who have
specific or special needs we have to
ensure that this war doesn't have
long lasting effects such as
school dropout
or school segregation
which would lead to social exclusion or
discrimination the fact that there are
no member state representatives here
today
is
highly regrettable
we must use
the tools afforded to us by digital
tools by digital means so that all
pupils and students can continue their
education
but that needs to be
an addition
to in-person teaching
all of this is happening at a time when
children need additional psychosocial
support that will be a way to give them
a normal life with school
sport
affection and a social life
member states must
recognize
existing diplomas and training periods
not just for students but for educators
what else can we do
it must be possible for students to end
their training
and education here because they're in an
urgent situation let me remind you that
we are dealing with an urgent situation
and we need coordination but above and
beyond that we must learn lessons from
this terrible crisis so as to ensure
that there is immediate support for
refugee children regardless of their
origin regardless of the war they're
fleeing from we must change approach
with an open system that will welcome
those who are fleeing war and violence
that includes children of course and
anyone who violates the rule of law is
an enemy of the european union
thank you very much
i now give the floor to our vice
president
dieter charenzova
a crying and exhausted little boy is
walking by himself with just one plastic
bag in his hands towards the border with
poland
tired mothers carrying their children in
one arm
and just a couple of belongings in the
other only where they had time to pack
crossing the border with slovakia
there are already four million of them
four million ukrainians who have crossed
the borders because their country is
being brutally attacked by russia
russian soldiers kill innocent people in
the streets rape girls and women and
torture children
but unfortunately danger still awaits
across the border especially for women
and children
they arrive to camps cramped with
thousands of people
suddenly a car or bus appears
and somebody offers to take them to a
safer place or so they say
we have a lot of disturbing information
that women have been taken away
drugged and forced into prostitution
and that there are ukrainian children
being trafficked and exploited
we need to do everything we can to
protect them
effective registration border management
are vital to secure the safety of young
and vulnerable ukrainians
all this could be facilitated by having
frontex on the ground to help local
officials deal with the immigration wave
and provide safe transport of refugees
further to other european countries
the european union can and should do
more to provide help in this area to
give support to the countries dealing
with huge numbers of refugees
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
that's what staten island
i now give the floor to mr daniel
caspari
college
i don't know how you
cope who have children but i have
tears welling in my eyes when i've seen
these recent pictures and mr putin is
responsible as the person who's directly
ordered these
bombardments we see also pictures of
fallen soldiers
of
mourning parents of destroyed
planes and tanks but also destroyed
houses
hospitals
cultural installations
memorials
these are pictures that many people have
already noted
innocent people have found their lives
destroyed and everything they have taken
away from
them
uh i'm at a loss for the words i can
hardly express my feelings here and
seeing
the pictures that we're forced to see
from buka i think we all fear
the situation but we are at a loss
because this is actually happening
and as a father of children i know that
it is our responsibility despite this
sorrow that we should act and assume
more responsibility than we have to date
we have to provide genuine help for the
ukrainians to help them defend
themselves against this aggression
we shouldn't just apply sanctions but in
our member states in the cities towns
and municipalities they should be
implemented for example if i look at the
veltamzontag the german newspaper
there are many local authorities who
still haven't applied these
sanctions properly and words fail me so
there are a lot of people have fleeing
ukraine many people have mentioned that
but let's think beyond the day of today
my gross my grandmother was
expelled from the sudetenland
she always spoke of her homeland
and that's why it's important that we
help ukrainians to win this war and that
together we then
assume our responsibility to help
rebuild ukraine to help ukrainians
rebuild ukraine and so that most of
these people as many as possible can
return to their country and rebuild what
was once there thank you
thank you i now give the floor to mr
lopez aguilar
johansson thank you commissioner since
the 24th of february
the world and the eu of course
have
been shocked
by the aggression
of putin against ukraine and its people
it's been a tight vendor
a paradigm shift four million people
entering european
territory
and the overwhelming majority are as we
know women and children who are
extremely vulnerable
it's therefore so important that this
important adopt this resolution which
provides support which also demands that
the french presidency and commission
provide a coordinated response
it should start with the registration
and identification of all people
it also
looks at
whether children have disappeared
where
might they have disappeared to
it also
looks at
ngos
which have become a bit overconfident
and
it would provide actual
secure passage
for people so that they can reach places
where they can be warmly welcomed
and this resolution would provide
adequate funding so it wouldn't just use
aim if it would also use the european
social fund eu react and all available
instruments would be used so as to
provide financial support to the member
states
as they
receive
so many
vulnerable women and children and these
people are going to be with us they're
not going to disappear overnight and
there's also the issue of the
change to the temporary protection
directive we also need to provide
information to these women and children
so that they are protected from
trafficking
networks
that's why it's so important that we
protect children and we protect people
against prostitution and it's so
important that the commission clamps
down on all forms of trafficking and
prostitution accept the blue card from
our camper
yes
please madam camper
they have a blue card
thank you very much i'd like to ask mr
lopez aguilar
it's okay thank you very much
i'd like to ask
one question to mr aguilar
given what he said
i'd like to say
that children are being registered in
poland they have access to education
they
are already attending schools
some
1 200 children
are in polish hospitals all this is
taking uh
place but this is at the charge of
polish
government
is it true that you wrote a letter
to
a
blog funds
for poland will you withdraw this letter
because we all need funds to support
refugees
mr lopez
the effort
of the frontline countries such as
poland hungary
slovakia and
romania is being recognized throughout
the union
however
they are not the final destination
countries these people are moving to
estonia czech republic austria so this
is a
new period and there will need to be
enough funding you are talking about a
letter which was not a personal letter
it was a letter that i wrote as the head
of the libre committee
this was
asked of me by the spokespersons by the
coordinators of libay yes the frontline
countries deserve support however
you must still comply with the rulings
of the ecj the european court of justice
particularly as regards hungary and
poland thank you
stefan now we will continue
on our list of speakers mr lauren vince
now
thank you for the fortune
domnar commissars college
madam commissioner dear colleagues in
romania we have over 650 000 refugees
and over 80 000 of state 43
percent are minors and 24 000
um
of school age and some are unaccompanied
but apart from these numbers we're
talking about broken families by this
horrendous war bloody war it's hard to
imagine the tragedy that these families
are going through these families that
live behind their lives and
their father father they might never see
again
making sure that these children and
young people are integrated in education
and medical care should be a priority
for the eu and for the member states the
romanian government
and local
governments and
civil
society
as doing its utmost for ukrainian
children who want to keep studying
online or who want to go to romanian
schools and um because on the border
with ukraine we have uh
ukraine minority ukraine community that
already has schooling in when we in
ukrainian we've managed to help a lot of
um refugee children to go to school you
see how important
education is in minority languages
and uh just like the resolution is
calling for
national authorities need to be
supported in order to overcome
linguistic barriers for these children
we
need interpretation
foreign language courses and special
programs in order to recruit
ukrainian speaking teachers and
teachers who speak other minority
languages in ukraine this is what i
told president uh
mathola when i visited the border with
ukraine and we should not um forget that
uh these children are ukrainia's future
and we hope that they'll be able to
live in a country that is reborn from
its ashes the ashes of the bombing thank
you very much
thank you very much the next speaker is
mr leshard miller but i don't see him at
the moment
he's not present so the next speaker
will be
adam leonard
two minutes you have the floor
president
ladies and gentlemen
president commissioner you answered the
horrific
scenes
are things that will not forget
the 10 million people who are displaced
within
ukraine people who've been forced to
leave the country especially women and
children i went to visit the border
of romania
things are calming down the
steady flow of incoming people but it's
not on the up
we
see that most people are managing to
find
private families to get support families
relations
i did see a
snapshot of this but the personal
impression of
the contribution that individuals are
making and the cooperation with
organizations be at europa frontex
or with the anti-trafficking coordinator
they're doing everything
they're trying to be everywhere at all
times to help the member states
one
sentence
we hope for the best but we're prepared
for the worst that remains with me so
commission council
ladies and gentlemen we have promised
our support we've promised protection to
the children and women who come to us
and we see what the services are doing
madam commissioner we see
the staff who are working around the
clock the member states and the agencies
nevertheless we still need to continue
working on this because our promise for
protection should not be broken
we need to know where the people are
where the children are how they need to
be provided for where the women and
children are as well
and we have to do our utmost and do
everything in our powers to make sure
that people don't disappear
that women don't end up in
disappearing then resurfacing in
prostitution or being exploited
exploited we need as a
solidarity platform we need to work
against those trying to exploit this
situation and more cooperation with the
agencies but the most important
aspect and almost
very simple is registration registration
registration
[Music]
thank you very much and the next speaker
is mr antonio lopez history is white two
minutes
so you have the floor
thank you president dear commissioner
um
my colleagues and i in the intergroup of
our children's defense of the children's
rights we have been many years
denouncing what is going on with the
children escaping for wars in syria in
iraq
afghanistan and now now is the question
of ukraine
and i have to tell you uh
children and young people
always
pay the highest bill
in wars
even if they survive
they have traumatic scars which up in
their lives forever
others fall into the hands
of
people who will exploit them monsters
who kidnap children to exploit them
sexually
as slaves
or for organ trafficking
there is a generation of children at
risk right now we must have a robust and
coordinated system at the borders with
officers who will protect children we
must help neighboring countries so that
children are registered in schools they
mustn't be robbed of their schooling
years which is so important we must
rescue vulnerable ukrainian children
particularly those who are in
hospitals
institutions especially if these
children are children with disabilities
we mustn't forget about unaccompanied
minors or war orphans and there are
thousands and thousands of those who are
at the borders right now
colleagues in the light of the barbarity
in butcher
in the light of what's happening we must
defend our european values one thing
must be crystal clear
the children of ukraine are our children
their future is our future it is now the
moment to act thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much and the next
is the catch the eye procedure
the first speaker is mr milan zver
two minutes so you have the floor
thank you very much president
my colleagues have said
everything that needs to be said and has
quoted all of the relevant figures
i have to say that the member states
have to play a major role
with their programs including erasmus
certain things needs to be restructured
we shouldn't just help refugees going to
europe but other young people as well
young people in ukraine
the decisive role for us
is that we help those young people
so that they can survive
and get an education
we have good education systems in in
slovenia and europe which could help
in slovenia
we've already taken in refugees
children
have started school the day after they
arrived in
sorry children have learned to play to
speak couple of words of slovenian the
day after they arrived in slovenia
that's important we must to expand we
must expand erasmus not just within
europe and eu
but
also extended to ukraine
where young people are still living and
need our help
thank you very much the next speaker is
maria grappini
thank you mr president madam
commissioner dear colleagues first of
all let me thank
romanian citizens but also polish
citizens moldovan czech
citizens and so on citizens who in
countries that have welcomed refugees
and we're talking about a very important
issue we talked about it in liber
endeavour as well and uh last night
madam christian i couldn't ask you this
but i will ask you now of course
children are our future and we need to
be protected regardless of their
nationality and uh here we talk about
ukrainian children no we need to to uh
treat all children the same we can't
have any double standards for children
from afghanistan africa syria no matter
what children are our future this is why
i believe that we need to protect them
all and um
their nationality doesn't matter another
thing madam commissioner just like you
said in our committee is that the
countries that
very that carry the biggest burden have
their own problems and we need funding
we need funding to fix this in romania
romania we have our own poor children of
course we need to welcome the refugee
children coming from ukraine but it is
unfair that we cannot give them what
they need and apart from
structures and platforms and so on
solidarity we need money and madam
commissioner i want to ask you something
because as i was listening to what's
been said today and and there's no talk
on about a third option of of uh
stopping the the this
horrendous death of millions of citizens
of course the sanctions against russia
and help for the refugees but what about
the diplomatic way is it still is
everyone still using it
european institutions the u.n the u.s
nato have a historic responsibility in
order to do everything they can on a
diplomatic level to put an end to this
horror this is uh horrific not only for
ukraine but romania's remains asking
what's going on when will the war stop
and it's a it's a danger for all of us
and we need to not forsake the
diplomatic way and tell us what to
answer to our citizens when they ask us
about the war thank you
thank you very much the next speaker mr
andrews two minutes so you have the
floor
yes thank you mr president and
commissioners and colleagues um
it's difficult to add something new
at the end of a debate but i want to add
my voice of shock at the evidence of war
crimes that we've seen
over the weekend
and that have been very articulately
expressed by so many colleagues i want
to raise one issue
which is the criticism of the
international committee of the red cross
which is triggered by the decision by
peter moore to visit
sergey lavrov in moscow ten days ago and
photographs that emerged of mr moore
seemingly smiling with mr lavrov and the
decision to open an office in rostov
just inside the russian
uh
inside across the russian border and we
had an engagement with members of the
rada in asobson and helena yanchenko and
their criticism of the icrc was palpable
and very understandable because clearly
russia has carried out breaches
systematically of international
humanitarian law whether it is
collective punishment whether it is
summary executions as we saw in bucha
whether it is the targeting of civilian
infrastructure so that criticism is very
very understandable
nevertheless it is clear that the icrc
are mandated very clearly by the geneva
convention and its first protocol to
observe the humanitarian principles
which means impartiality independence
neutrality and humanity and and that is
a very difficult thing for the icrc to
do and it's very difficult for members
of the rada to accept
so my recommendations are twofold first
of all that the icrc should be
a lot more sensitive in the
circumstances where there is clearly an
asymmetric asymmetric
approach to respect for international
humanitarian law where the russian side
had been so systematically in breach and
i recommend that dg echo would if
possible open a dialogue between
leadership of the ukrainian
rada and the icrc on the other hand in
order to find a way for mutual
understanding thank you mr president
thank you very much
the next speaker is bogdan zoncha
two minutes so you have the floor
president commissioners this is a very
good debate thank you very much
and it's a very important resolution as
well but i think that we should
already start preparing another
resolution
about the fact
that we have to start an investigation
into what the russian barbarians are
doing in ukraine we
do have europol euro just we have the
hake tribunal we have the prosecution
office in ukraine all these institutions
should start working together
in order to hunt down the bandits
who are
killing
innocent children and innocent mothers
in ukraine
i think that this resolution should be
adopted by acclamation
and the international criminal court
which
has only given three judgments so far in
20 years
should not have mercy on these
perpetrators because there is a lot of
evidence that these russian barbarians
are killing innocent children thank you
catherine thank you very much the next
speaker madame catherine akinichi two
minutes you're on the floor
thank you very much
president
during my contribution of one or two
minutes
i'd like to say that there are a lot of
children who've been forced to flee
being forced to leave their
own homes
children who are traumatized who are
vulnerable especially those who come
from institutions from hospitals
children with disabilities
war orphans
miners in general they run the risk of
ending up in the clutches of
smugglers
i know that we have to protect the young
but i'd like to point out that we i was
the first to
sign the resolution in the european
parliament concerning
children
who are fleeing war
it's a resolution that was pushed by the
intergroup
for
young people i'm the co-chairman of that
group
and i think we need to do
undertake greater
efforts we need to make sure there are
humanitarian corridors in place we need
to provide psychosocial support
we need to provide guardians for
unaccompanied minors
mechanisms to
make sure there's accommodation in
various member states and access to
education systems these are just a few
of the measures
that the european institutions and
national member states
institutions need to take immediately
now to protect children children are the
first victims of an absurd war yeah
thank you very much
next speaker is madame berta kemper two
minutes madam you have the floor
president
uh commissioner
ladies and gentlemen
until
the ukrainian children and women are
safe
until
a
voting receives
its
his petro dollars
nothing will stop him
i
agree with mr joins uh
we
need
a way
to
uh
persecute
russian
criminals
polish
uh law enforcement
is now
collecting evidence uh from children
these children are
being deprived of their childhood
and in
poland right now
1222 children are in polish hospitals
we have also received the number of uh
children with disabilities they are
now
safe in poland we are also helping in
ukraine
i
visited lev uh this
weekend we provide help
and
everybody
wants us to stop putting and they
give us thanks
and
finally a very important
last minute
thing
some 400
exploited
children
ask for rehabilitation psychological
help abroad
the commissioner also mentioned
specific funds and
for example
poland
is using
the state
budget and uh
individual people are helping but we
also need uh european funds thank you
for this debate
we have to stop
putting and protect the children
thank you very much the next speaker is
marcus ross
two minutes so you have the floor
thank you how would you feel if your
children didn't go to school for a month
what
consequences would this have on their
schooling this is actually happening to
millions of children fleeing from the
horror of war in ukraine
our obligations go beyond words we need
concrete action which will help those
who have left everything behind a
fundamental issue
when
a child is developing is their education
every day a child doesn't go to school
doesn't play with their classmates and
interact with their teacher is a lost
day for their future it's a lost day for
europe's future too the european union
must ensure that refugee children can
have their right to learn we need more
teachers more teaching material
better infrastructure
schools and centers must be able to
welcome children with dignity so we need
the right infrastructure we need
investment we need staff we need
european funds in addition
we need to
focus on
recognizing diplomas and academic titles
many ukrainian students and ukrainian
young people are already
at
university
and when they're fleeing from the bombs
they don't think about grabbing their
university degree or their university
certificates so then they have a problem
getting their qualifications recognized
we need to make it easier for their
qualifications to be recognized what is
the commission going to do uh
on that subject
the
war shouldn't
prevent uh
young ukrainians from having a future
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed the next
speaker is
mr victor agresco two minutes so you
have the floor
mr president dear colleagues madam
commissioner
the situation is dire 1.8 million
children
fled ukraine 2.5 million children
internally displaced in ukraine
we're talking about 60
of children in ukraine
these are destinies
people children who need our help and we
cannot turn a blind eye to this
it's not enough to talk about access to
schooling to healthcare and so on we
need
to do something we need to do something
together and we need a
minimum basic services for these
children and for this we need
money we need a common
action at the eu level and we cannot
leave this
burden on some member states some member
states including romania that i
represent here in the eu
have done a lot of put in a lot of
effort but we need to do more we need to
come together with all our efforts and
at the level of the eu budget we
asked for
uh
for uh common resources for these
challenges and in order to be able to
give an integrated help to these
children just like we said before every
regardless whether we're talking about
access to education access to housing
to health care there are lots of things
that need to be done not just right now
but over the long term and
madam commissioner i'd like to thank you
for
your efforts to find a solution
to this with the member station i like
that member states especially those who
contribute more to the budget of the eu
to do more and the council is not here
for this important debate and this is
why it should we should go um further
and i was at the border just like other
colleagues and uh i've done a lot to
help children we all need to come
together because the rights of children
are human rights thank you
thank you very much and the next speaker
is dominic ruiz de vesa two minutes so
you have the floor
senior president
thank you very much president
i also thank commissioner johansen for
being here
and
for her address more than one million
ukrainian children are now on european
soil
we don't know how long the conflict is
going to last their right to education
must be safeguarded whatever happens
however it's also important to point out
that
all refugee children deserve this
education if they're fleeing from war it
doesn't matter if they're syrian afghan
ukrainian or any other nationality
african
students living in ukraine who are also
fleeing from war
have been instead sent to detention
centers in poland
that means that they are not able to
continue with their lives or with their
students
in poland or elsewhere in the union
in poland there have been entire syrian
families with young children
who have also been detained in some of
the
border
camps
between belarus and the eu
we can't have an eu system based on
discrimination which
is hypocritical
we have to ensure that
all refugee rights are upheld
children's two
but every single age range
for this to happen we need a european
assistance plan
so that we can provide support to the
millions of refugees in europe but also
so that we can deal with the energy
crisis the energy price hike and what we
need as to ensure and
our defense and so that we can help
ukraine with its heroic defense of its
country and its territorial integrity
thank you
thank you very much
and in conclusion on behalf of the
european community
we're here from ulva johansson
thank you very much mr president
what makes us human
i think it's the ability to imagine
to realize
the reality of another human being
to feel
her
fear
to feel her suffering
to feel her hope
her love
i would like to thank you all for this
very good debate
i would like you to thank you for your
engagement and solidarity as well as
your readiness to act
ukrainian parents
want us
count on us to protect
their children while they are
out fighting for their country
for our
shared european values
and i know that i can count on you in
the european parliament in this effort
many of you have mentioned education
just to answer some of the questions
through cohesion funds
we help integration integration into
kindergartens into schools into
including including language courses
we are ready also from the commission
side to publish school books in
ukrainian and to support technology
providers to develop digital educational
content
already today this morning more than 160
ukrainian
children went to school in an eu member
states and this of course need we need
to step up
two weeks ago uh the ukrainian minister
of interior denis monasterski spoke to
the extraordinary council jha council
or the ministers of interior
he told us
about
the terrible numbers of reports
of children
witnessing
their fathers being killed
their mothers being raped
again
and again and again
many of you have spoke about these
terrible war crimes
i want to tell you that the eu has set
up a joint investigation team with
ukraine to collect evidence and
investigate war crimes and crimes
against humanity
the eu stands ready to send
investigation teams on the ground to
support the ukrainian prosecution
services and as i mentioned earlier both
eurojust and europol stand ready to
assist
and as i also just told you in the
beginning the protection and support to
the refugee children are at the top
priority of my 10-point plan that is
going to guide the commission's work the
coming weeks
again thank you very much for this very
good debate thank you for your
engagement and thank you for your
readiness to act this is what we need
now to protect children in war thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much that brings
me
um
the next debate is on trans-european
energy infrastructure